same exact play let's see  so they switch it again up top lopez  goes away from the larger man  and now a.d gets to work draw a double  team and we'll see what happens  three on the shot clock james with the  long  three and knocks it down lebron  james with his sixth  three-pointer  [Music]  an eight-point lead for the lakers  you may say this is lucky or late no  this is what you want as a guard  you want somebody taller and slower on  you so you can  shoot without a hand in your face yeah  his hand is up but it's not in his face  and it's all because he switched the  pick and roll with a smaller man on a  seven footer  the seven footer got the space he wanted  and got it back out to lebron  lebron he saw it and watch him call it  he's going to call it  because players know this is in practice  every single day you bring us  bigger guy out it's an easier shot for  the smaller player  because you have a speed and advantage  and a speed and advantage in the speed  category